NBC sports.com NFL columnist football
morning in America it's a must read for
football fans and you can see it every
Monday at NBC sports.com as we make way
for the great Peter King back on the
program
Peter kind enough to join us during the
season Peter sauntering in wearing pants
looking good people oh good to see you
buddy thank you Peter King okay yeah and
I wasn't sure what the topic was going
to be prior to yesterday's news and then
when it happened and then you said you
know you still like to come on you had a
Kobe Bryant story we will talk football
because there's a few things to talk
about obviously it's Super Bowl week but
where do you want to start with the Z
and I one day last week I insanely got
up at 3 o'clock in the morning and rode
to work with Andy Reed so that was the
lead to my column wrote it on Friday
filed it was all set and was just
cleaning up some of the loose ends and
my column on my way down here yesterday
and so you get the news of Kobe and I
had just this one thought that you know
the first day the San Diego Chargers
became the Los Angeles chargers 2017 the
PR guy Josh Ruprecht who used to work
for the Lakers and a new Kobe very well
asked him to come in and talk to his
team about what's it gonna be like to
play in LA what what is that whole thing
gonna be like and so Kobe comes in he
tells him a little bit about LA and then
he asks for questions and someone I mean
I can't figure out if the New York Times
a book review planted this question but
said Kobe what's your favorite book and
he said Jonathan Livingston Seagull and
so ok explanation please
and he just said you know this is about
a nonconformist who was tired of
fighting other seagulls for the scraps
on the beach and it wanted something
more out of life he wanted to be truly
great at everything and so his whole
thing was hey you're in the NFL guys
great good job but
what else is there do you want to just
settle for being one of sixteen hundred
guys who play professional football or
do you want to truly be great do you
want to really you know be the best at
flying which is what Jonathan Livingston
Seagull want it to be and then do you
want to get great at other things and
not only is it an NFL story because I'm
sure a lot of guys in that audience the
Chargers are devastated today just like
everybody across America is but Jonathan
Livingston Seagull is the Kobe Bryant
story he was great at one thing he was
great at flying he was great at playing
basketball and now with his detail
series with coach and his daughter with
doing all these other things in life he
wanted he wanted to be great at
something else
that to me is the real tragedy of this
not to mention the other people who died
including
you know his absolute sweetheart of a
daughter so I don't know Dan I I never
met the guy I don't know him at all I'm
not an NBA guy but I just I just am
incredibly sad about it just like
everybody else is yeah the word that I
used in the word that always came to
mind with Kobe was curiosity yeah I was
just he was curious and there are
certain athletes who are like this
they're curious beyond their sport I
mean Kobe didn't want to be defined by
oh you're a great basketball player he
wanted to be defined by more than that
you win an Oscar I remember he came on
and he said what am i doing up there
winning an Oscar but in my mind you know
why you're up there winning an Oscar
because you planned on doing that I
don't think he would ever go into this
going yeah I don't know maybe I could
win an Oscar I think he was so gory
goal-oriented plus to take on that you
know Tom Brady never said I don't think
publicly hey I want to be as good as
Montana if not better like what are they
sports do you have a guy say and you
know Mike's leaving and Kobe says manure
giving me but the baton great if you're
not I'm taking the baton yeah he wanted
to be greater than Michael Jordan wasn't
afraid of that I don't know what other
sport where like Tiger I think probably
said hey you think Jack's great I'll be
better than him
and I think his father kind of
reinforced that but I don't know how
many sports where you'd have somebody
who's iconic you know did Peyton Manning
say hey I want to be better than Joe
Montana
I think Peyton's the kind of guy who I
think said it quietly and I bet Tom
Brady said it quietly too because Tom
Brady was absolutely determined he was
not gonna let the 199th pic stand in the
way of him finding some way at some
point to be great it's I think it's so
interesting when you compare the real
real great people I remember Brady
telling me one time that if one of the
best things that happened to him was
being a sixth-round pick because nothing
was expected of him and then as time
went on it was you know early in his
second year after he'd had two training
camps a full offseason program after you
know his selfless ethos Belichick knew
what that was why did Bill Belichick not
go back to Drew Bledsoe in 2001 when
Bledsoe was healthy because quite
honestly he liked Tom Brady better at
that moment than he like Drew Bledsoe
and you can say well how was that
possible Bledsoe is the highest paid
quarterback in football and you say well
it's because Brady comes to work every
day and he does one thing not that
Bledsoe didn't do this but Brady comes
to work every day and he does one thing
how can I make the team better and so
that to me is what makes a lot of these
guys so great because I think Kobe
Bryant was exactly the same LeBron is
the same now and and so I I think it's
that that he wanted to be absolutely
great at what he did and even though
basketball was over he was gonna find
another world to conquer he's Peter King
from NBC Sports joining us a little bit
later on Jerry West will stop by Reggie
Miller will join us as the amazing you
got Jerry West Wade he'll be great I've
had it I've had a great relationship
with him and I I had mixed emotions on
telling Fritzi to reach out to him
because I I wanted him to grieve yeah I
mean I I you know that sensitivity in
sensitivity and it's a fine line where I
think he came in because of your
basketball career
that's what it was there's a couple of
football items here with Brady now the
Patriots didn't they issue a like a
deadline I saw that Adam Schefter said
that on Twitter the other day which
surprises me because I think that the
Patriots are probably looking at what
happened to them last year on the day in
late March that Rob Gronkowski announced
his retirement that was the same day
that Jared Cook who was the apple of the
Patriots eye if Gronk retired agreed to
a contract with the New Orleans Saints
so they don't want to get stuck holding
the bag I think the big problem is right
now how can Tom Brady know two days
before free agency starts what he wants
to do I mean honestly dan what's gonna
have to happen is that people would have
to reach out to him illegally you know
Tom Brady wants to play football he
doesn't necessarily not want to play
football for the Patriots so I don't
know I think it's kind of unrealistic I
believe that if you really are grateful
for what Tom Brady has done for your
organization for two decades you say hey
Tom listen you take your time you do
what you want now there's a chance in
the meantime that we might and we'll let
you know but we might sign Teddy
Bridgewater we might make an insane
offer on a restricted free agent like
Taysom Hill we might do something else
and we'll tell you but we're not going
to wait until April 23rd when you have
decided ok I'm coming or I'm not coming
and so I get that I I think it's a
little bit dangerous if if it's true
that they want him to decide two days
before free agency because clearly Tom
Brady I think wants to smell the roses
there's a reason he wants to be a free
agent it would defeat the purpose of
being a free agent if the Patriots give
you a deadline before you can become a
free agent and that to me are just
reading it from the outside that's
pushing Tom Brady away I also found it
interesting that Brady wrote a letter
to the hall-of-fame voters to support
troy polamalu did now I did that for
Jason Taylor and maybe Jason Taylor
needed a little bit more than Troy
Polamalu
I was surprised that it feels like Troy
Polamalu and of course you've been in
that room and been a voter joy Polamalu
when I hear the name is a Hall of Famer
I would agreed and I don't know I mean
I've done it for 28 years and for 28
years I've been surprised at what
happens when we walk out of the room and
two hours later we see it announced
who's in the Hall of Fame because we do
secret ballots we don't nobody knows who
anybody else votes for so that did I'm
not saying it surprised me but I'm not
positive that there's a lot of it a lot
of stuff that's deep and dark about that
I wouldn't be surprised if somebody just
reached out to Tom and said I know you
admire Troy Polamalu would you give us a
few thoughts about him or write a letter
for him and and he did and quite
honestly
Minoo what I'm trying to think of
somebody else on the list who we played
a lot but I think I mean let's say John
Lynch I don't know how many times he
played against him but a few I bet if
somebody asked Tom Brady to do that for
John Lynch he'd probably do it too I
don't know that but a nice exact Thomas
I don't know if he would yeah that's it
that's it that would be a good one too
because obviously he played him he
played Thomas a lot the five year window
how does that help or hurt Eli Manning I
think it helps him a lot
at least because I I shouldn't say helps
him a lot I think it helps him because I
remember you know going back to Kurt
Warner there was so much because Warner
had the highest highs and he had the
mediocre estudio kurz you know I mean he
had a huge donut hole in the middle of
his career but I think if you basically
sit back and you appreciate what he did
you know in those years when he was with
the greatest show on turf and then he
had the rebirth late in his career with
the Cardinals I thought that that
allowed us allowed me anyway to
basically sit back and have some clarity
right now you know there's
it's like the Democrats and Republicans
you've got two sides on Eli Manning
screaming at each other you've got the
one side saying - it's like that into
saying I don't think it's bad and have
you seen Twitter over the weekend I mean
I've seen the impeachment I have I have
but but I mean you know you got one site
saying to incredible postseasons cannot
erase 16 years of almost all mediocrity
you know he that's he defines mediocre
in so many ways and I don't mean that in
a negative way I mean that you know
that's just the fact of what happened to
him but I mean I agree with those who
say well if you have two of the greatest
postseason I would bet then of all
players in the 100 year history the NFL
will they have been doing championship
games and playoffs for that long but 85
or 90 years he's had two of the five to
ten best post seasons of any player in
NFL history and so that really has to
count for something you know beating the
great Belichick and Brady twice in their
absolute prime so we'll see I'll leave
you with this the reason why the Kansas
City Chiefs are favored in this Super
Bowl is why I mean if you're favored by
one point does it matter
isn't that the line but doesn't it feel
like San Francisco has a better
offensive line defensive line better
secondary you get to push with the
coaches probably with plate falling yeah
wide receivers you'll go with Tyreke
he'll tight in as a push with Kittel and
Kelsey isn't this just Patrick mahomes
is better than Jimmy Garoppolo I mean
the stat that is really important in
this game in my opinion is that since he
entered the league
Patrick mahomes is the most efficient
quarterback with the most yards and the
highest rating when he gets pressured
and has to throw in less than two and a
half seconds and I know that sounds
ridiculously analytical Pro Football
Focus nerdy stuff but think about it if
you're forced to throw when a if you if
you get to a quarterback within two and
a half seconds
that's really good and every time it's
two-and-a-half seconds or less he's the
best quarterback in football in his
first two years in football so that's
pretty good there's one thing out I just
believed from my ride took a ride with
Andy Reid as I said and I think Andy
Reid I just get this sense that whatever
happens he has a real peace with what
happens in this game because he knows
that his quarterback is going to be an
extension of him on the field in all
ways and so I think that's why Reid's
comfortable today when do you make your
pick I don't I don't know I was thinking
about picking the 49ers and then I
thought I kept thinking about that stat
now I'm thinking about picking the
Chiefs and hopefully nobody will care by
the time I make my Friday nobody will
pay attention and you know when people
come up to you and they say who do you
like in the game and it feels like
there's a gambling tinge to that like oh
god that somebody's gonna go on the
plane yesterday some guy asked me that
and he said what about the over I think
I think there might be a lot of points
but what is the over you know I never
give you money when you're right and
they always blame you when you're wrong
that's that's right then maybe Peter
thank you for stopping by Dan thank you
we appreciate four more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]